hallo mein name ist luca und damit
beinahe schon alleine gerade wir machen
heute zusammen was und zwar hat
sebastian 7 sammeln von youtube-videos
vorbereitet und mir gleichzeitig muss
den titel seiner neuen wohnung
deswegen warte warte aus direkt ohne
strich ich glaube es ist ein video von
apa red doch lieber lassen die person
recht
die person muss nicht mehr ohne raten
die wache ist nie drauf kommen was ich
schon überlegt immer so ein bisschen wie
die leute da aussehen was sie darstellen
sollen also wie hinaus wie akkurat und
eine andere person und ein kind von das
video
also ich würde sagen die wahrheit aus
wenigen solche fbi agenten oder
türsteher
ich versuche kein gesicht verändert aber
relativ gut geraten punkte
ich habe keine ahnung die machtmittel
aus dem video deswegen mittelpunkt ich
habe die zwei punkte wagen war bei sap
ich sag nicht ich will punkte der hand
noch nicht aufgenommen
also vielleicht das kann nur gut sein
weiter sollten sondern in direkte frage
ist denn unglaublich im tipi irgendwas
mit roboter schießen war vom roboter
waffengesetz auf jeden fall
[Musik]
ich mag waffengesetze roboter direkt auf
die titelfeier der in etwa zwei wochen
hatten spricht jetzt gerade die heiße
titel militär bringt robuster
verschieden mit waffen bei und und wenn
du das auch richtig schwer
so verschwand oder sagte schwer ist also
ungefähr in ponte die eigentlich aus wie
sie typische kuchen sybil group holding
immer solche tendenz also ich würde
sagen ich hatte gedacht ich bin mega ich
sage kuchen tv youtube drama das kann
man echt schwer erkannt werden zuständig
die sache mit liga marschiert album das
am 11
das ganze geld was sie mit ihrem sieg
weiß nicht ob das tier etwas neueres
video ist wo sie sagt dass sie diese
erholung grafen figur halten kann seiner
der ist erst nicht gesehen habe war das
heute meine entscheidung gerade ist
schon sehr beeinflussen gibst du mir den
tipp eine riesengroße bei youtube es
gibt ja was macht ihr wissen leute
typischer bewertet der autofokus ist aus
natürlich auch wieder ganz schwer zu
erkennen welche die für beendet
alle youtube kennt also wird sie werden
jetzt besteht die kondom challenge das
video heißt 100 consumer um handy bringt
die frage dass das ist von ihnen danke
ich habe jetzt drei und dann mach ich
[Gelächter]
weiß dass ich auch in dem video mit
dabei war auch was ich war dritter hat
er auch der tempel die wand gedreht
sowie wände micro eingegangen auf die
bühne der familie geschoben
also videos von reden korrekt ich würde
sagen video titel irgendwie youtube
dumme fragen stellt dumme fragen an
youtube interview irgendwie sowas in der
richtung dummer youtuber stellungen
youtube fragen als ok alle benutzer habe
ich bei mir eigentlich schon kann man
die tollen punkt für die mitte spielt in
der familie zu erwarten zeigt dort
insgesamt fünf davon wieder meine damen
und durchgefallen hätte gerne mein like
that kanal hat noch ein video
hochgeladen command bild rippmann titel
ausgegangen ist sagte ich ihnen nämlich
gezeigt
dann steckt einfach den link in der
infobox aus und jetzt befindet in der
hellen k beide davon er hier findet hier
eine 2 die eigene wert darauf den
kontinent
kostenlos abonnieren tut das mache ich
immer dass nur die hälfte bei der
zuschauer wirklich auch argumente da
oben findet ihr auch meinen shop
eingeblendet wie gesagt erster juni neue
sommerkollektion neue produkte vor und
jung-stars video ist scheiße